doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
pilati
für sie ist das falsch dann lassen wir
los einen frühen morgen los sg haitz
gierig ist ein freund klarer worte und
mit solchen begrüßte die interessenten
für seinen gast fokus diese soll
flüchtlinge fit machen für den schweizer
arbeitsmarkt ja für die schweizer
gesellschaft allerdings seien ein blick
ins kurzprogramm wirkt nicht gerade
verlockend eher abschreckend sie werden
sehr viele schweißtropfen haben sie
werden manchmal fluchen sie werden
manchmal böse sein mit mir das weiß ich
jetzt schon aber das ziel
das ist klar abschluss mit diesem kurs
das bringt sie weiter werden ich habe
hier typische schweizer normen also zb
die pünktlichkeit in der schweiz
das ist eine norm da steht nirgends
geschrieben aber jeder weiß es die
schweizer werden böse wenn die menschen
zu spät kommen und genau hier lernen sie
solche sachen
jedes mal wenn sie etwas erleben und sie
merken dass der schweizer börse wird
dann ist irgendwo hier etwas falsch
gegangen oder sie wissen es nicht bereit
sein neues zu lernen
die schweizer sind manchmal wie die
schauer nur so aber so geht es nicht in
diesem großen müssen so schauen
ich kann ihnen 100 prozent garantieren
diejenigen die den kurs hier beginnen
werden die werden nach einem jahr eine
komplett andere person seien 100 prozent
kommen sie bitte am donnerstag nur wenn
sie den kurs auch machen möchten
[Musik]
vier tage später
erstaunlich viele sind wieder erschienen
gesetzte damen gesetzte herren recht
herzlich willkommen zum zweiten mal
heute geht es um die sprach einstufung
nun wird selektioniert denn es sollen
nur die besten einen platz erhalten
micron co leiter des kurses verteilt
einen deutschtest
sie möchten die berge nach zermatt
fahren können sie zur marktzeit ist ein
ort wie emmenbrücke luzern
der markt ist ein ort jetzt müssen sie
eine kurze e-mail schreiben dort an die
touristeninformation in diesem e mail
müssen sie fragen wie viel die hotels
kosten in sein hotelzimmer in zermatt
wie unwirklich schön muss das für jene
klingen die auf ihrer langen reise in
einem boot auf dem mittelmeer oder in
den straßen italiens nächtigen mussten
risco heißt dieser kurs für flüchtlinge
seit acht jahren angeboten von der
branchenorganisation hotel & gastro
formation heinz jähriger in gelernter
koch und erwachsenenbildner entwickelte
diesen kurs war somit wer sie sehen ich
weiß nicht wo sie herkommen das war noch
nie und wenn wir mal das bad mit seiner
schafe und tastatur brauche noch
eigentlich schon jetzt muss ich sagen
große teilbeträgen ein interessanter
schweden
aber wolfsburg fahren wir haben das weiß
ich dann wie lange sind sie schon in der
schweiz 23 seit drei jahren ein
schwieriges problem es möchten mehr
leute den kurs besuchen als plätze zur
verfügung stehen
warum soll ich sie wieso sind sie besser
als die andere
[Musik]
sollten mehr zeit ist afghane und wirkt
er in seiner heimat als übersetzer für
die amerikanische armee eine riskante
tätigkeit in afghanistan
märz wurde bedroht und musste fliehen
was würden sie anders machen oder
verändern in der zukunft vielleicht
wurde von cia geworden sind sieht
bereits in der schweiz wie lange sind
sie hier
33 jahre
wir haben sie schon einmal in ihrem
leben in der gastronomie gearbeitet
nein noch nie noch nicht okay was
zeichnet sie aus sie sind eine eine
friedliebende person und das haben sie
das gefühl das wird am schwierigsten für
sie kochen werden das ist erstmal dass
das ist die küche der kloß gelegentlich
auch flüchtlings lehre genannt findet in
der kantine der einstigen textilfabrik
viskose in emmenbrücke statt
[Musik]
erste schritte in einer schweizer küche
der kanton luzern bezahlt die einjährige
ausbildung
sie soll die flüchtlinge schließlich in
den arbeitsmarkt führen in die
selbstständigkeit
denn bislang leben dieser menschen von
der sozialhilfe und es besteht wenig
hoffnung dass sie ohne ausbildung da
herausfinden
frauen die er liebt und nicht zu ihrem
hus kommen einfach nie in den unterricht
geht steht der persönliche so groß dass
einfach der ball eckig und und sie merkt
es für andere und wie sie eine hochzeit
und die einzige chance und können so vom
sozialamt
überhaupt war die crew ist drinnen
ausbildung das ist die einzige chance
warum ich weiß warum nicht deutschland
und italien aber warum sind sie in die
scheiße ist und eine bekannte plan für
die menschenrechte würden sie denn gerne
in der gastronomie arbeiten
was würden sie denn gerne machen eine
fristgerechte vorbringen
kochen sie zu hause auch jetzt diese
lehrgang geht ja ein jahr
es wird sicher ganz schöne zeiten seien
hier ein jahr kein bau sind keine
erwähnt werden kleine ferien nichts aber
was denken sie es könnte für sie ein
problem sein
in diesem kurs habe
es wird jetzt wird punkte die
pünktlichkeit
wir haben aber ich bin sicher sie werden
sich daran gewöhnen wenn sie es wollen
[Musik]
ssg gott sie ist gut behütet in einer
mittelstandsfamilie in kampala
aufgewachsen der hauptstadt ugandas
dort hätten fanatische evangelikale
christen auf hass menschen gegen
homosexuellen als journalist und
menschenrechtsaktivist setzte sich für
die rechte der homosexuellen rechte die
es in uganda nicht gibt in diesem land
setzen zeitungen die namen von
homosexuellen auf ihre front seiten und
geben sie dem volkszorn preis kann da
ist eines der schwulenfeindlichen länder
der welt dessen autoritärer präsident
yoweri museveni hat für homosexuelle
langjährige gefängnisstrafen angeordnet
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie haben nicht polizei informiert sie
müssen auch bestrafen werden so das ist
eine schwierige situation in uganda von
homosexuellen und noch immer versuchen
heinz gehrig und mike kohn
herauszufinden wer am besten in den kurs
passt warum haben sie die schweiz
gewählt als neue heimat
warum ist die schweiz das beste woher
die schweiz ist kein problem keine leute
hat keine probleme aber wieso soll ich
die zu nehmen
sie müssen besser sein als er sonst
nämlich hin und weil es gerade gut
gesundheit und habe aktiv und ich habe
wirklich und ich immer guten teil
richtigkeit ihrer arbeit gekommen
gibt es noch andere gründe warum sie
nennen sollte das hat uns jetzt gemacht
ja wenn ich habe gearbeitet aber außer
haus beißt er ist mir gearbeitet und ich
brauche geld
ok
[Musik]
saba zerai lebt mitten in der schweiz
und doch fast nur unter ausländischen
nachbarn die gegend am rande der stadt
luzern heisst im volksmund das gitter
die 39 jährige frau aus eritrea wohnt
allein in einer 1a wohnung
[Musik]
gelegentlich rüstet sie den kaffee auf
eritreische art dann lässt sie das
fenster offen stehen wegen des rauches
der feine würze gerecht geruch ist im
halben quartier zu riechen und zieht
manchmal landsleute an
heute jedoch lässt sich niemand blicken
[Musik]
die heimat von sawatzki ist eine
verarmte ein parteien diktatur eritrea
steht in einem dauerkonflikt mit seinem
nachbarn äthiopien als lehrerin ein floß
sawatzki den national service einer
staatlichen zwangsarbeit minimal
entlöhnt und ohne zeitliche limite eine
trostlose situation die in den letzten
jahren zehntausende junger eritrea aus
dem land vertrieb zuerst in den sudan
dann mit dem lastwagen durch die wüste
sahara ins bürgerkriegsland libyen
stationen einer lebensgefährlichen
flucht die ihr traumatisches finale auf
dem mittelmeer fand 2000 dollar bezahlte
sabbats für diese letzte etappe in einem
überladenen schiff bis zur rettung vor
italien aber als aber es kommt alles
leben
3 weg vom lieber in die nacht die schiff
ist sie macht so besteht ist ich weiß
nicht wie lange sie laut würde weinen
die kapitän alles weggehauen wo haben
sie von der schweiz gehört das erste mal
im leben wenn ich mit ihr lebte viel mit
uns editorial kommt hier in der ich weiß
noch bei internet machen mit dieser
events wo bist du
wir gehen nach italien vor hinterher
jetzt wir in schweiß wesentlich 90 weiß
ist besser alles in italia ist
die leute ist ins wasser schlafen
keine schule keine arbeit keine formale
aber mehr als das leben
seit zehn jahren ist sabbat herein und
auf der flucht
so lange schon hat sie ihre familie
nicht mehr gesehen
die einstige lehrerin muss in der
schweiz wieder ganz unten anfangen was
es ist auch schon mittwochmorgen viele
einheimische schlafen zu dieser zeit die
fasnacht aus für jene flüchtlinge jedoch
die es in den ressorts geschafft haben
beginnt heute der unterricht die
verwandlung in eine arbeitsmarkt fähige
person mehr als 40 personen worten
kommen und wir haben nur platz für 15
also viele von den gesichtern die sie
vorher gesehen haben sind nicht mit was
ich ihnen jetzt sage ist hart aber es
ist so
niemand niemand in der schweiz hat auf
sie gewartet niemand niemand
das heißt sie müssen zehn mal besser
sein aus all diese schweizer die hier
sind und keine stelle haben sie müssen
besser sein als die und dann haben sie
eine chance das werden sie auch
zum start steht das fach werte und
normen auf dem stundenplan
womöglich das schwierigste schulfach für
diese menschen aus einer anderen welt
doch zuerst führt kursleiterin doris ob
man die klasse durch die schule
räumlichkeiten und schon bald läuft in
der lage eine kleine wertedebatte gut
ausschauen sie es ist keine frauenarbeit
bügeln können alle das heißt wenn ich
morgen und übermorgen zeit habe werde
ich nur männer trainieren
ja ich bin auch nicht gut
die ersten lektionen befassen sich mit
den grundlegenden dingen des lebens
dinge über die man nicht so leicht
spricht und biete stehen sie nicht auf
die toilette
also die toilette ist nicht zum
draufstehen sangen zum draufsitzen und
wenn sie jetzt lächeln
ich habe das schon gesehen und darum ist
es auch wirklich ganz ganz wichtig mit
diesen burschen etc
die sind da zum duschen und nicht für
pippi woche christen muslime buddhisten
sind hier versammelt doch das soll keine
rolle spielen
sie können die welt anschauen wir haben
über 30 verschiedene kriegs hörte und
imerys entweder die politik da geht es
um das oder das ist die religion
religion grundsätzlich müssen sie sich
gut merken es ist absolut unwichtig
welche religion sie haben das ist
absolut unwichtig wichtig ist dass sie
eine haben haben sie die
die sie haben und dass ich die richtige
weil welche die richtige ist das weiß er
auch nicht
nun hat es also begonnen dieses
schuljahr ohne ferien der
deutschunterricht ist zentral
die deutsche sprache das wichtigste
werkzeug um überhaupt in die hiesige
gesellschaft zu finden
zwei praktika in restaurants und hotels
werden folgen
rund 80 prozent seiner schülerinnen und
schüler bringt heinz gehrig jeweils so
zu einer anstellung diesen menschen wird
eine große chance geboten doch geschenkt
wird nichts
die anforderungen sind beinahe
erdrückend so viel neues so viel
unbekanntes es wird viel schweiß fließen
in diesem jahr und manchmal fließen auch
tränen
[Musik]
willisau im luzerner hinterland
seit fünf jahren lebt der 19 jährige ali
haschemi mit seiner familie in der
schweiz seine eltern sprechen kaum
deutsch
die hp miss lohan aus afghanistan
einem land das man seit über 50 jahren
nur noch als land des krieges kennt es
blieben ja schon besonders ali haschemi
lebte mit seiner familie in massa
einer heiligenstadt des islam
sein vater führte dort einen kleinen
laden
sie arbeitete von kindesbeinen an im
väterlichen geschäft eine schule hat er
in seiner heimat nie besucht
krieg und gewalt trieben die achtköpfige
familie in die flucht iran türkei
griechenland italien
die mehrjährige gefährliche reise ins
ungewisse hat den buben geprägt
wenn kleine falsch macht oder so dem
geschäft verloren
für mich alles ganz genau war was meinen
sie was falsch machen
der weiß was er dann musste er nach
chicago zu sagte strunz langlaufende
bonds wären zehn cluster zu laufen
es ist aber halbwegs sie und dachte sich
die schafgarbe krank also schmaler weg
ist und so zieht situation ganz genau
nur gelaufen machen
das ist eigentlich und wie auf 10 610
millionen zu
und ich bin selbst wirklich dass die
kontrolle und das tun sich zu
entscheiden
es ist wohl anders das ist schwierig
stück sie den kulturellen unterschied
dass er die meiste mühe gemacht alles
ziemlich alles kann mich nicht auskennt
ich habe alles gewonnen
ob die fluchtgründe der familie haschimi
und der anderen flüchtlinge in diesen
fällen dem asylrecht genügen kann er
nicht beurteilt werden
fest steht einzig das heute über 100.000
flüchtlinge in der schweiz lebe
anerkannte vorläufig aufgenommene und
neu angekommene und dass die mehrheit
davon wohl bleiben wird was soll mit
ihnen geschehen mit diesen vielen
fremden menschen und erneut versucht
heinz gehrig bei seinen schülern den
sinn für werte und normen zu schärfen zu
zeigen das was hier geld andernorts
unverständlich ist und umgekehrt
auf allzu große feinheiten kann er bei
seiner weltreise allerdings keine
rücksicht nehmen wenn sie durch die welt
reisen
dann können sie ganz böse überraschungen
erleben
als gierig malt mit dem breiten pinsel
in china ist es absolut normal dass man
überhaupt auf den boden spuckt wenn sie
in brasilien sind dann dürfen sie nie
persönliche fragen stellen
alles was persönlich ist ein tabu und in
österreich könnte man meinen die sagen
hallo wie in deutschland aber hallo
kommt gar nicht gut an weil ich verstehe
auch nicht was bei dem halo falsch ist
aber es ist nun mal so und das ist
typisch deutschland nur deutsche kommen
auf die idee irgendwo auf dieser welt in
die ferien zu gehen und einfach nackt in
den sand zu setzen und da bin ich kein
anderes land führte das machen aber
deutschland macht das und darum denken
sie wie thema daran werte und normen das
ist nicht richtig oder falsch
in diesem land ist es so und
in dem land ist es so und am besten
fahren sie einfach wenn sie in dem land
wo sie sind das annehmen wo in diesem
land noch mal ich kann erläutert heinz
carrick die regeln dieses kurses
formuliert als vertragliche vereinbarung
wir sind pünktlich im unterricht was ist
das größte problem wenn jemand
unpünktlich ist hat man das gefühl er
ist auch nicht zuverlässig und das ist
ganz ganz gefährlich denn unzuverlässige
menschen die kann man im ersten
arbeitsmarkt nicht brauchen was bedeutet
dieser begriff sauber selbst clean her
ja wohl also etwas das saubere ist einen
sauberen tisch das gegenteil ist
schmutzig dass wir müssen daran machen
muss sauber schreiben warum wieso können
sie dann nicht schmutzig sei nicht ihr
problem wenn sie stinken
warum ja damit sie auch gesund bleiben
mal schauen sie diese länder wo ein
sauberkeits problem haben wo probleme
haben mit der hygiene da sind
automatisch die menschen viel kranke die
regeln sind nun klar und auch was
passiert wenn diese mehr als zweimal
verletzt werden
wir haben gelbe karte wir haben gelbe
karte und nachher rote und rote heißt
arrivederci es kommt jemand anders
von den wänden lächeln den flüchtlingen
die beruflichen vorbilder entgegen
adrette glücklicher menschen wir sie in
dieser fülle nur in diesem teil der welt
zu geben scheint zieht bald so auch das
eigene leben aus
[Musik]
so jedenfalls ist der plan dafür setzen
die kurs teilnehmer ihren handabdruck
unter den vertrag
der chor das jetzige
ich habe zehn und ich von augenmedizin
erreichen
[Musik]
früheren in oberland unterhalb von re
feiern und heinz gehrig der strenger
lehrmeister
jetzt muss ganz ganz ehrlich sie mit
ihnen und die ehrlichkeit
das ist zwar unter die lupe mit metro um
phantasien in der schweiz und war der
teil des deutschschweizer lang lang mit
der fantasie und das ist realität
realität ist herd kalt und brutal und
die wo sich energie bringen und das
nützt einfach nur ja wenn ich ihnen sage
ich versuche das konnte ich irgendwie
scrollt nicht sondern du hast keine
antriebe auto muss hier lebt heinz
gierig mit seiner frau andrea das paar
zwei erwachsene söhne als jüngling macht
der gierig eine kochlehre das berufs
diplom nutzte er als ticket die welt zu
erobern
[Musik]
heinz gehrig kochte auf allen
kontinenten in südafrika arbeitete er im
berühmten hotel sun city
er hatte die südafrikanische
staatsbürgerschaft angenommen um
leichter an arbeit zukommen
doch dann lernte der junge schweizer die
grausamkeit der apartheid kennen da sind
sich nicht auch eine zur arbeit und in
texas wo bleibt dir und dann aber wieder
aus einem auto am nachmittag hört man
noch immer das klönen und das und
eigentlich denkt also das war nicht
einmal gut wenn schweizer richtlinie
würden einige frühe berger insel rügen
oder mal anders
es geht um einfach ein besseres frieda
heizung und als gierig soldat und teil
dieses rassistischen systems hätte
werden sollen
floh er nach mosambik der schweizer
wurde selbst zum flüchtling
[Musik]
schon in seinen jungen aus ganz jahren
hat heinz gehrig erkannt dass die
schweizer geburt kein verdienst ist
sondern einfach ein großes glück deshalb
sind für ihn heute alle menschen
gleichermaßen ausländer
das sagen sich nur russland ruft er über
all das geht gar nicht anders
und der grund ist ganz einfach egal
welcher religion man angehört oder so es
ist keiner guckt wurde bevor du möchtest
du gerne mal cool also mckagan nicht
wählen die über glück und der schweiz zu
holen und die beobachtungen die eben
nicht geglaubt
wir müssten also heinz gerichtet auch
als prüfungs experte
heute sind in zug die absolventen einer
verkürzten lehre als küchenangestellte
zur prüfung erschienen
oftmals sind es leute mit
migrationshintergrund die wegen
sprachproblemen keine eigentliche lehre
absolvieren können
nennen sie mir doch bietet vier
verschiedene ziel teils garrigues
bemühen dahin aus seinen schülern
schweizer zu machen
das probiere gar nicht dass sie so nicht
möglich probieren ihnen aber die
attribut oder die verhaltens wiese mit
ska damit sich noch der einfach erkannt
aber ich gar nicht um so eine partie
weiteres witze machen schweizer weitet
aus wie dem sinn und stolz für mich die
anderen das schweizer werden
nein es geht um sich dort zu integrieren
jetzt haben uns
so das war so 23 das sehen wir dann
einfach auch gut gold
[Musik]
was mache ich mit der bürste frei
sie wissen dass das velo knapp 100 er
selbst kenne da weil es geht nichts
schlimmeres als wenn sie auf der
toilette setzen kann man kein wertpapier
dass die inflation auch passiert und
stellte sich vor das passiert uns einen
gast
das ist peinlich wird der coach
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie machen wir die tolle zeit
er kann es ein bisschen einfacher dann
machen wir so ein spitz ganz einfach und
nun ein leben dann kommen wir den grund
sorgen dass man zum schluss einen spitz
macht über das ist also begrüßung
wenn also schon die geburt und genau
wenn sie so ein eingeschaltetes werte
papier seien dann wissen sie automatisch
vom kopf her auch diese toiletten
gereinigt
die sauber sind das nur die ganze übung
das war eine große sache wenn sie dann
täglich es gibt doch eine geräumte vor
einem zwischen reinigung eine
grundreinigung dann könnte es noch eine
saison einigung 54 50
die kurs teilnehmer bekommen ihrer
berufs kleider angepasst
sultan wird so wird die uniform
allerdings nie tragen
in einigen tagen wird der afghane den
kurs überraschend verlassen
seine eltern die als flüchtlinge in
pakistan leben sind die not und
benötigen dringend geld als
hilfsarbeiter auf dem bau will der sohn
dieses geld beschaffen
wer eine stelle findet darf den kurs
jederzeit verlassen
[Musik]
der abgang von sultan märz erweckt bei
heinz gierig die stetige gefühl wenn der
täter öffnete um schafe mit kann sich
noch der lösung vom sozialamt foto klein
zur behandlung verengter beispiel das
ziel erreicht auf der anderen seite bin
ich eigentlich enttäuscht wenn ich
anstatt dass die stellenzahl heutigen
bauen um vorübergehend ist und dass
vielleicht wenn der coaster fertig ist
natürlich nie
also ich das eigentlich mit ausgiebigen
tabelle aber super geeignet das hatte
ein genialer mitarbeiter darunter bin
ich überzeugt er hat 100 prozent sterben
er hatte mir untergebracht
die schweiz begann für taschen vor zwei
jahren im asyl empfangszentrum
kreuzlingen der täter war 17 jahre alt
ein junger mann ohne jegliche
schulbildung doch offenbar intelligent
und mit einem starken willen es hier zu
schaffen
denn heute spricht und schreibt der
erstaunlich gut deutsch der junge
tibeter lebt im luzernischen altishofen
[Musik]
haben sie überhaupt gewusst dass es die
schweiz gibt na ich weiß nicht nun weiß
ich also amerika hat ist genau jetzt
sind sie zwei jahre hier liegen der
schweiz was haben sie viel träume für
die zukunft zu in zukunft also ja so
kommt ihr gerade so ich arbeite und ja
wenn ich also gut so werden dann also
ich hoffe meine älteren hinterher
springen konnte
cha cha cha wuchs auf dem elterlichen
bauernhof auf
dass die chinesen seine heimat seit über
60 jahren gewaltsam besetzt halten
bedrückte den bauern buben sehr
[Musik]
nachdem er kritische flugblätter
verteilt hatte wurde er von der
chinesischen polizei gesucht
versteckt in einem lastwagen und zu fuß
floh der 15-jährige durch die berge nach
nepal
ich habe ja so seid ja vier jahre mehr
als 4
also meine mit meiner ernten konnte
gehabt und nicht also gehört in
altishofen bewohnt tasche mit zwei
landsleuten eine gemeinsame wohnung das
rezept für die tibetischen track taschen
stammt von seiner mutter mit der er
nicht in kontakt treten darf weil er sie
sonst gefährden würde
wenn tasche nach hause schreiben könnte
wie würde er seinen eltern die schweiz
schildern also die die menschen sind
sehr nett und her ist sehr gute
organisieren oder so diese sehr gut und
und ja hier ist also demokratisch ist
selten dass ihr vor einfach kollege
marco grigoli reagiert höhere durch
künstler musst du heute sagen wir auf
fußball hat sie erst in der schweiz
kennengelernt
seit einigen monaten trainiert dabei den
a junioren vom team die cutterin fußball
die große integrations maschine
das grand hotel national in luzern
heute beginnt ali haschemi in diesem
traditionsreichen fünf-sterne-haus sein
hauswirtschafts praktikum läuft ein
bisschen über betreut wird der junge
afghane von einer portugiesischen
mitarbeiterin die abläufe scheinen klar
und simpel doch in einem solch gehobenen
haus sind selbst beim bettenmachen und
putzen viele finessen zu beachten
[Musik]
die verständigung ist nicht ganz einfach
da alice portugiesische betreuerin kaum
deutsch spricht
fünf wochen soll das hauswirtschafts
praktikum dauern
es ist ein neues ungewohntes
arbeitsleben für ali haschemi wird es
durch die das ist schwierigste
ja
etwas außerhalb von luzern gelegen das
hotel hermitage in diesem vier sterne
haus beginnt heute sei die
hauswirtschafts praktikum
[Musik]
betreut wird die eritreerin von dh papa
eine äthiopierin eine von 90
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in
diesem haus deutlich die mehrheit davon
sind ausländer
schaust du heute ist montag dann ist
gibt das kommt und das ist dh papa kam
vor 14 jahren als kriegsflüchtlinge in
die schweiz
die junge frau musste im fremden land
allein auf die beine kommen
eine ausbildung wie sie nun sah batterie
machen kann
davon konnte sie nur träumen es waren
auch jahre der verzweiflung bis sich die
äthiopierin endlich in der schweiz
zurechtfand
ohne dich brachte schwierig aber man
kann auch mit gottes hilfe
es ist aber heute 14 jahre später geht
es ihnen besser und sie haben hier tritt
gefasst in der schweiz ist sehr schön
jetzt jetzt ist sehr viel passiert
können die kunden
ich kenne alles ihr habe meine arbeit
ich habe wo ich bisher alles selber und
ich bin stolz auf mich weil ich habe
alles geschafft ist auch die arbeit geht
die heute zufriedenheit mike kohn der
co-leiter des fiesco kurses ist
unterwegs zu einer ärgerlichen
besprechung im hotel national ali
haschemi hat seine praktikumsstelle
verloren weil er mehrmals unentschuldigt
nicht zur arbeit erschienen ist
die hoteldirektion möchte bei diesem
gespräch keine kamera dabei haben
der putz braucht mitleid und brachte mir
war das größere mit dem sechsmonatigen
also dann der ton ist problematik liegt
vor allem eigentlich als in der nächsten
erster linie gemeinsam anhand qualität
eines renault liefert es gut aber
seriösität fällt und dann immer ganz
klar mit ihm darüber diskutieren sagen
bis gut und habe ich aber nicht gut was
macht erwartet und so dass man so
verbessert oder mit ihm
wieso sind sie ein praktikum verließ das
zu zeigen vertrag zu kommen
und 11
wenn ich mit dem atrium schaffen muss
ich sprach keller post ag sei nicht mit
dem abschaffen
so kann sie mit einer portugiesischen
was wollte ich erlebe das wort hört sie
hans für ein kommentieren groben 7
ich kann so manches telefon und
techniken im telefon nicht ab so dass
nicht die hand im praktikumsbetrieb
verloren
sie haben das kurzzyklische verloren sie
hat zwei verwarnungen kassiert die der
kurzen zeit da sind sie mir fehlen und
große probleme
sie sind wirklich dort motiviert das
stimmt sie mit top motiviert und die
software läuft wie da komm ich nicht ich
einfach ich hoffe mein lieber freund
da ist noch eine verzögerung ja da
stehen sie die hans wasser schon bis zu
den aus lieme und sie sagte der minister
weil der flüge sei sie hans nun im
begriff der kurs der kostet viel geld
und es gibt hunderte tote wo das auge
ein bild machen und darum würde mir nur
die richtige lied in dem kurs züchter
scout falsch investiert
da können wir das zum fenster bemerkt
genau wie viel und das wette ich nicht
ich bin sehr dankbar dass er so ziemlich
viel zu hoch an
april startet das mainboard als immer
wie viel zeit ich vorhin haupt und ich
habe erfahrung hat gezeigt dass avatar
ihres verhalten zeigt mir das nicht ich
habe mir gesagt hey geht nicht im hof
fotos stellt und sich behauptet
aber sie zeigt sondern sie zeigen jetzt
gegenteil sie behauptet sie viele
pubertierende teenager genau wie die
14-jährige was günther anders verbessere
zuverlässig sie also und wie picasa
was möchten sie damit sie zuverlässige
werden das machte freenet höhere für die
spk frühstück bekommen von euch von nun
an jeden morgen sagt sie komme vor dass
es im selben beruf gestanden
der aber der anreiz der winzerinnen
einen tag vor die verarbeitung dank
klatsche
es ist sommer geworden halbzeit in riaz
kokos wer wird die vielen prüfungen
bestehen
wer wird es schaffen bis ende jahr
durchzuhalten
[Musik]
der erste stock
noch sechs monate bleiben diesen
menschen aus aller welt um an ihr ziel
zu gelangen
trieb das stark
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav 4 4 x 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz